Goes to show you,
I'm going to find that we're back up.
Sorry.
You stream how tweet
everybody we're back up.
Yeah.
So the um,
you know that the way that the Shamans
continued explaining fifth dimension is
the dream state.
Um,
that's you access that sleeping and you
also access that on a general level in
psychedelic experiences.
Sixth dimension is the realm,
um,
is the spirit realm.
And uh,
the kind of the master that realm is
the earth mother is nature itself.
So the snakes that came,
that yields,
that came,
that's the fifth amendment.
The sixth,
sixth,
that's the sixth.
And what are we in?
We're in the third,
third and fourth time
operates Taj just time,
linear time.
And was in the fifth is the dream state.
The dream state.
Dream state.
The collective unconsciousness
of all humankind is the fifth.
And that's why when you dream,
you can access things outside of yourself.
Um,
you know,
think of things that you wouldn't have
thought of because if somebody else had
ever thought of it,
you know,
you can access that in
the fifth dimension,
the dream state outside of time.
So then the sixth is,
you know,
that's the spirit realm.
That's where if you're going
to communicate with any
of these totem animals or
guides or anything,
and they actually say when you smoked DMT,
you get kind of dropped directly
right in the sixth dimension.
And there's beings in there that you see
and it's very common report from people
smoking Dmt did you see beings?
And it's because you get rocket shipped
directly into the sixth dimension where
you're going to encounter these different
beings that exist in that dimension.
Um,
but the overlord of that kind of
dimension is his mother earth.
So a lot of the things you see
are kind of animalistic based,
especially for the people in the,
in the junk.
Maybe there's different paradigms of that.
But then the seventh dimension
beyond that is the realm of energy,
uh,
energetic vibration and
large and large entities.
And that's where they say the ships came
from for me was the seventh dimension.
And the purpose of the ships was to
prepare me for travel to the eighth
dimension,
which is the realm of pure potentiality,
they call it,
where you can really affect change
on all the dimensions before,
including the third and the fourth
affect change in the physical body.
Basically access,
see things in your life,
have a completely different
perspective outside of time.
And that's the eighth dimension.
Um,
kind of the final dimension
that you can arrive.
So,
um,
you know,
they explained this all after after
I had went through and then said,
okay,
this was where you were here.
This is why you're here.
And,
uh,
you know what,
based on my experience,
it might all sound crazy,
but it's a paradigm that,
that seems to work for me because I
lived it and I was there and I did it.
And I saw,
you know,
I've seen the physical benefits of
what happened when I got to be eight
dimensioned.
It wasn't like I just got there
and no good stuff happened.
I mean,
my business,
the decisions I've made,
I've been huge.
You know,
things are going really well.
My health is great.
Uh,
my buddy's good,
but who knows,
that wasn't very scientific.
I'm not going to put that
one up in the win column.
Uh,
cause I didn't.
I'm not,
you know,
I'm not that
what we experience in a hallucination in,
in that form isn't absolutely real,
but it's just we can't put it in a box.
Yeah,
you can't,
you can't weigh it.
You can't hit it with a hammer,
you know,
making noise,
you know?
Yeah.
But it's the idea that
is just your imagination.
People like poo poo that like
it's just your imagination.
What is your imagination man?
Your imagination is a crazy fucking thing.
All these neurons and cells are firing
and somehow or another through these
ideas manifest themselves or they can
manifest themselves as solid objects.
Like the person had figured
out the wheel or the guy wore,
makes a fucking computer.
These are all real things
that have somehow another
emerged into this dimension
from this ether old dimension of thoughts
and ideas and done it through a human
being.
And we look at it as like,
no big deal.
Like,
oh,
he thought of it and then he made it.
It's just his imagination.
Oh you were in the eighth dimension.
Sure you were.
That's just your imagination.
What the fuck is your imagination?
We are very light with our,
our appreciation of that and very light
with are very lax with our all as far as
what,
what the,
the dimension of the
imaginations brings us.
I mean it's,
that's a crazy fucking thing.
The idea that the uh,
the world of thoughts and ideas is
actually some sort of an intangible
experience that's like right there.
And from that you can pull things out
and create them in and put them and then
you stack them up on top
of each other and you know,
and then their physical,
they become a different thing.
But it's from the imagination.
Everything is from the imagination.
So the idea you saying,
you know,
anybody that would,
critique it.
Oh you saw drag Lawrence.
Sure you're doing it.
You saw snakes.
That's just your imagination.
I don't know what that exactly means.
You know,
when,
when you see something,
even if it's a hallucination and
it's changing your fucking life,
cause it's whatever it's teaching you
or whatever it's showing you or whatever
leverage that it uses to pry your ego's
grasp free of your life for whatever
amount of time that allows you to sort
of reset your rpms and fucking start a
new with fresh purpose.
That's real.
Yeah.
That's fucking real.
That UFO you saw was real.
It was real.
You know what I'm saying?
What the fuck is the imagination?
Does someone have to pour alloy into a
mold and carve those things on it for it
to be real?
Do you have to be able to walk up and hit
it and make a claim for it to be real?
No.
It's just how it interacts with you.
Any kind of invention was
made from your imagination,
so.
Sure.
So it's like,
who cares
if,
if they teach you how to make
the next fucking computer,
then don't say,
who cares?
It's just your imagination.
Cause that shit might teach
you something just like these,
uh,
tools from,
from,
you know,
the Egyptian Times.
They were,
you know,
tools out of their imagination.
Yeah.
And if you believe in things,
if you believe in things,
they have incredible power over you.
Yeah.
Both good and bad.
You know?
And who's to say that's not real.
You know,
there's like the,
the idea of the placebo effect.
Like I give you a sugar pill and all
of a sudden you feel better because you
thought I gave you medicine.
Well,
still you feel better.
You know,
people have actually been cured of
ailments because of the placebo effect.
So what the fuck is
happening where people,
people have this misconception
that it works only one way.
That you know that the
body can affect the mind,
but the mind can affect the body.
Oh No,
you can't go backwards on that road,
but it's bullshit.
I mean,
your mind can make changes in your body.
How do you think these,
you know,
these people are able to do things like
slow their heart rate or walk on coals
and not get burned.
I mean,
it's,
they're able to focus some kind of
walked down coals who's to trick.
Maybe it is.
I don't think,
I've never walked on calls,
but whatever,
you just gotta keep moving.
Well,
what they can do things with pain.
I mean you should have these people who
go to trans and really kind of stop the
pain from,
uh,
from affecting women and certain people
whose beliefs of certainly heal things
that the doctors thought were impossible.
But the idea that the mind can't affect
the body I think is one of the biggest
problems and misconceptions
in western medicine.
It's certainly Ken,
we all know people who are super,
super negative,
one up getting really sick too.
That's,
that's real.
There's,
I've had moments in my life where my,
I was too stressed out
and I wasn't balanced.
And those are almost always the moments
where you want them getting sick.
And there's a direct
correlation between that.
You know,
there's a direct correlation
between positive energy
and positive results in the
physical form.
Yeah.
You know,
they're all connected.
One of the DMT trips that I had never,
never forget this because it was
a real life changing experience.
Um,
you know,
the DMT trip is like being shot through
a cannon to the center of the universe
and all of a sudden you have all the
information around you all the time,
but it's like they're slippery dolphins.
He can't grab them.
It's like all the information's there,
but it's like you can't harness it.
You don't,
you can't figure it out.
And it's very,
very overwhelming and
it can be terrifying.
And in one trip that I had,
I got real scared in the middle of it
and I started thinking all this negative
shit.
It just got away from me.
And um,
as I was thinking all this negative shit,
the DMT trip became black and green and
dark and it became like Jag id and then
it just like,
it just looked harsh and it,
it looked like it started
to be almost like cancerous.
It looked like it was growing and it was,
it was moving in in an asymmetrical way.
It was just fucked up.
It was.
And then I realized,
okay,
this you're thinking negative,
stop thinking negative,
think positive,
relax,
let go.
And as I'm saying all these things,
the colors are slowly changing and then
when I completely relaxed and went boom
and it blossomed into these
beautiful geometric patterns.
It's like once I started
thinking positive and going,
oh,
okay,
this is just silly.
You can control your mind.
Think Po,
let go,
love,
boom,
boom.
It like showed me in a physical form,
like something that I could
actually look at and watch.
I could see negative energy and positive
energy and that the lesson was that
these can be controlled
to a certain extent.
They can be managed and they can certainly
be managed by your intent and your
attitude and your ideas.
Yeah,
no doubt about it.
I mean that's a,
it's a powerful lesson to learn
is to be able to manage that.
Not only when you're on,
I mean it's psychedelic.
That's like,
that's like when you're in the,
that's the real game time,
you know,
that's the playoffs.
That's when you need to bring all your
training and practice to bear because
it's,
everything is magnified.
You're under the microcosm.
You know you don't in
a real intense moment,
you don't know yourself until you
have a psychedelic experience.
You might think you know yourself,
but I guarantee you you're going to find
out who you really fucking art when you
go deep.
And then when you go deep and you come
back and you have to kind of assess
everything and you look at
yourself through fresh eyes,
the the ego while you're sleeping,
while you're working,
while it's gaining ground,
it's like the fucking fed.
It's stealing money and just pocketing
things and taking control over certain
areas.
It really is like the government,
and then you don't realize how fucking
embedded it's becoming your system until
you have a blowout.
He till have a psychedelic boom blow
out experience and that ego good.
Just shut the side.
Like,
you know,
like a fucking explosion and a comic book
movie and the Ego's sitting in a tree
with half,
it's close off hanging from branches
because it just got blown out,
you know?
Then,
then you get to see yourself again.
Then you get to see who you really are.
But the time off of that man,
you gotta be real
careful because that ego,
he fucking gets out of that tree,
fucking brushes himself off and clings
a whole deal and starts running shit
again.
Listen to it be a lot easier
to just let me handle this.
I got this,
I got this dude,
you're the shit.
Okay you're going to do this
because you're the fucking man.
Trust me,
have a seat,
I'm going to drive.
And then next thing you know the
fucking Egos in control again,
your life is fucking confusing.
I think that's why it happens.
Even to the Shamans,
you know the masters,
this is not something that they're,
you know,
void of,
cause they get a lot of power in their
little communities and things and so the
medicine has to bring them back.
Well you're,
you're a spiritual person,
but you're also,
I mean the idea of spiritual did
the word is a weird tainted word.
Unfortunately the word spiritual,
so tainted,
you know,
automatically hippy nonsense comes
into play when you start using that.
But the line is your,
you are thoughts and ideas,
but you were also a physical,
biological being a vehicle and
just like your fucking car.
We have to change the oil and you have
to make sure that spark plugs are in
[inaudible] setting correctly and
make sure that the computers tuned up.
Uh,
you have to do that
with your body as well.
Your body is a vehicle
and if you ignore it,
much like your fucking car started
spewing out black smoke and shits out and
dies on the road,
your body does the same goddamn
thing it's your car can do.
If you don't maintain it correctly,
it will fuck with you.
It will fuck with you.
And you know,
and the ego is a part
of the physical body.
You know,
it doesn't seem like it is because again,
you can't fucking measure it.
You can't beat on it with a hammer.
But it is a part of who every fucking
living organism that wants to stay alive,
that has a conscious,
a consciousness and has the ability to
recognize that it's here that has self
awareness.
The Ego comes into play because
that's how you stay alive.
That's how you succeed.
That's how you get girls.
That's how you fucking get money.
You get money,
you work for the ego.
The Ego is,
it's a part of the machine,
but it can get away from you.
You've,
you know what you're saying there,
it touches on the very core of
my entire philosophy in life,
which is balanced.
You know,
and that's what the warrior poet is.
It's the,
you know,
it's the Samurai that appreciates
the cherry blossom tree.
You know,
it's the,
it's gladiator when he's walking
through the fields of wheat and in,
you know,
appreciating that it's the ability to
maintain that kind of balance of both the
physical side and the
spiritual side and a,
and really that's,
I think the message I
had one message to bring.
It's like you got to have both.
You can't just be this spiritual being
only and go on these trips and stuff.
You got to hone your body.
You got to keep it healthy.
You got to be able to operate
in this world because in this,
in this dimension you're in,
you know,
people aren't to,
lay down for you just because you
have a higher spiritual truth.
Like you have to bring
both aspects to bear.
And I think that's what
we were supposed to do.
And I think every,
but almost everybody has
to whack on either side.
You know,
there's the big muscle
heads that are like,
oh yeah,
fuck that hippie bullshit crystals,
eighth dimension,
that fucking faggot.
And then there's this,
you know,
the other side of things that's like,
they have no sense of humor,
no sensor,
like almost academic in,
it's all energy.
It's all love.
It's all light.
And then someone fucking snatches
their purse and they're like,
oh my God,
there's something wrong with the,
you know,
like protect your shit.
You know,
like both sides are applicable.
And I think that's where people are
flawed and they're so vigilant about
protecting their little niche.
Like,
my shit is right.
I'll pound you if you drift,
you're wrong.
And if you believe something else
and the other people are like,
you're just an ignorant ape,
you know,
on the other side of things and no
one wants to kind of bridge that gap.
But our birthright is to have all of it.
And that's what we should strive for
is complete balance in both of those
aspects.
And I think,
I'm hoping that's why,
you know,
some people will listen to kind of
what I'm saying is because I tried it,
I tried to be able to do that.
Like I want to kick ass in business
and still talk to people about,
yeah dude,
like I went to another
dimension and it was crazy,
but I'm over here.
I'm going to be killing it,
you know,
in your world too.
So don't think I'm slipping,
you know?
That's what I'm trying to do.
And that's my goal.
A lot of people want to,
uh,
push aside or deny the
importance of the physical world,
the,
whether it's capitalistic gains or
whether it's keeping your body fit and
sexually attractive.
They want to deny the significance
and importance of these things.
And the,
you know,
the meaning of these things almost as
like a form of socialism because they
don't want to compete and they don't
want to have to be sexually attractive.
And so women will say,
Oh,
is that what you care about?
you're shallow.
You care about what someone looks like,
no,
I'm a human being.
And if you're fat,
that's gross.
Okay.
That's just the way it is.
And you can pretend all
you want and you know,
maybe you'll take fat
with a grace personality,
uh,
over skinny.
That's a con.
Yeah.
Maybe to make some
compromises and you know,
no one's perfect physically,
but let's be honest about what we're
looking at and what you like and why you
like it.
And that goes with capitalism as well.
That goes with being a successful person.
You know,
there's a lot of people
that think that some,
there's some things shallow about being
monetarily successful and I think that's
a form of socialistic thinking as well.
It's like you want this to be a level
playing field because you can't compete.
And that's really what it is,
you know?
And you've got to find your
fucking place in the Sun Jack Ass.
And you know some people I will,
I will never be playing
professional basketball.
I'm five foot eight and I don't run
that good and it's just a fucking,
just the way of the world band
and they ain't a fair world.
Okay?
You got your own hand.
This is your journey.
You deal with the hand
that you're given and,
and,
and just find your fucking place.
But don't try to hold other people back.
Don't try to say there's something
wrong with that girl being sexy as fuck.
Don't think there's something wrong.
But because that guy's got a
six pack that makes girls wet,
you know when they see him,
you can't hate cause you're fat.
You can't hate your all.
But he's,
he shallow just going to the gym all day.
I'm sure he's really
interesting to talk to him.
Maybe he is.
Maybe he's more interesting than you.
Stupid because guess what?
It only takes like an
hour a day to work out.
You're telling me that all those other
hours of the day he has to be doing
meaningless meathead.
Shit to make your paradigm work.
No,
you're just,
you just want to pull
the playing field down.
You're not trying to level things now.
You're not trying to rise.
You're trying to,
everybody's above you,
your crabs in a bucket,
man.
Your social crabs in a bucket.
Yeah,
that's absolutely right.
Not a bitch is out there folks.
And most of them are men.
How about that?
Remember that when you hear whiny conti,
negative,
stupid shit from dudes,
you bitch,
saddle the fuck,
fuck
up.
Yeah.
It's uh,
you know,
I think back a long time ago,
and I think we've touched on
this maybe on the last podcast,
but you know,
you had to go to war and in
some countries you still do.
And I think that's why that
Israeli dude was so cool.
Like everybody in Israel
goes to war and he was like,
listen,
the kids are a little unruly or whatever.
But when you,
you know,
but the parents don't
care because they know,
you know what 19 you're going to war.
Like Israeli army is active.
It's very active.
It doesn't rest,
you know?
So that's one kind of last
people that's holding,
but still they're fighting with
lasers and a lot of things.
I mean,
not this guy,
he was running it,
fighting with shit that we
give them trippy situation.
Now there are about the size of Rhode
Island and they're surrounded by no hate
them.
I know.
So countries all over the place to
hate them and some of them have nuclear
weapons.
Yeah.
But the fact that each one
one has to be a warrior at some point,
you know,
I think it,
it impacts,
there's more character.
Yeah.
Impacts the culture.
And that's the way it used
to be back in the Roman days,
you know,
I mean,
every philosopher,
like I said,
Socrates was a bad ass.
You know,
every philosopher had to be,
they ran campaigns with swords and stab
barbarians in the throat and then talk
philosophy over some wine later.
And that's,
that aspect is largely ignored,
I think.
And,
and one of the,
one of the large,
uh,
sicknesses I think of
our world is they are,
like you said.
Yeah,
we definitely talked about this before,
the coming of age ceremony.
The,
this,
the,
the ritualistic aspect of,
you know,
making a big deal of coming of age
because I think that's something that's
missing from this world.
Cause I think that kids today,
like they don't know when they're a man,
you know,
one of your man,
you Manary 22,
23.
Yeah Man,
we dad still calls you a fuck head.
You need to borrow money.
He's still a man,
you know,
when do you become a man officially,
and then a lot of Eh,
you know,
cultures,
there's a ceremony,
you know,
like those,
uh,
the guys in the Amazon that
do that bullet ant glove.
Yeah,
we saw that tree by the way.
Fuck Outta here.
It's an ant that bite you,
it stings you.
And it feels like your arm is being
slammed in a car door for 24 hours
apparently is blinding,
unbearable pain.
And for the coming of age ceremony,
these crazy motherfuckers take these
ants and they give these oven mitts and
they,
they make them themselves and these,
they're all poorest and they stuffed
the ants in there so the ants can't go
anywhere.
And you have to shove your hands into
these gloves filled with bullet ants and
mother fucker.
That looks scary.
That tears just streaming down these
men's faces as they were going through the
ceremony.
Will you get through that?
Man,
you have the right to
say you're a man now.
You know what I'm saying?
Like you feel like this is a very clear
boundary of broken through and you know,
I wouldn't suggest bullet ants.
Yeah,
well look at what happened to Ari,
you know,
as you,
and a little bit,
but think about it.
I,
I often think about it,
home of
politics,
you know,
like,
I feel like politicians should
have to fucking earn their place.
Like whether it's bullet answer,
like a five steps psychedelic,
you know,
trip where it's like,
all right,
you want wanna,
you want to lead us,
here's what you gotta do first.
You're going to go take a boga 24 hours
is going to cure you of your addictions
of bucking blowing coke off,
gay intern cock,
whatever you're into.
It'll,
you know,
at least the Copart,
maybe not the gay in turn.
I don't think it ever cure that,
but uh,
you know,
whatever it's going to whatever your,
addictions are cigarettes,
heroin,
coke,
whatever,
a Bogo,
blast that out of you.
24 hours.
All right,
so you go from there.
And then I think they should have to do
a fast for a week where they get smoked
out every day and have to control
their hunger and not eat and think.
And then after that,
like maybe go and do the Io Osca,
you know,
and then from there,
bring a bipartisan group to a
campfire where they all do mushrooms.
It just talk about ideas and shit and
then hit fucking session all drop a cap,
a pure pharmaceutical grade MDM,
boom.
Now you're just making these people party.
But listen,
I can get those good drugs,
man.
Imagine how different it would be
if they had to do some kind of,
imagine how different it would be
if they had to go through bootcamp.
Just that go through some something
that shows your character other than the
photographs of your cock
that you send to your intern.
They busted him.
Another guy,
they busted another fucking politician
t sending pictures of his cock today.
Some fucking new guys resigning.
I don't even know who he was.
Just some dumb ass who thinks it's okay
to send pictures of his Dick through his
fucking cell phone.
Some chick who turns out to
be working for the enemy.
Wow.
Yeah,
he was kind of set up.
Yeah.
He was set up.
He's a fucking fool.
He looked like a fat 50 year olds.
Probably couldn't believe he
was going to get some pussy.
It's how I see your cock.
Okay,
here's my cock shit and next thing you
know these pictures around the net and he
looks like a fucking idiot and now
he's got to resign and God damn man,
they're allowed to do that though.
Just because they're,
they have their job.
They're not allowed to do
that on their off time.
There's still men
because they pretending they're someone
else because they pretend to be family.
Men with great Christian values and
loyal to their wive and their vows.
But meanwhile,
they're sending cock pictures
all over the fucking Internet.
And so you know that this is
a person who's full of Shit.
And this is a person who can't be trusted.
His character can't be trusted because
he's pretending to be something he's not.
It's not like Tommy Lee sending
pictures of his Dick and you're like,
oh,
Tommy,
you know,
it's fucking Tommy Lee.
He's crazy.
He's married to Pamela Anderson.
We've all seen his dick.
You know what I'm saying?
It's like if Tommy Lee was sending
pictures of his Dick to girls,
he'd be like,
well,
my Dick look like that.
I missed that.
It fixes of it though.
You know,
it's not like that.
When someone pretends to
be something they're not,
and we know they're not,
we know that there.
There's no way.
Most politicians can
really be the way they are.
You remember how John Edwards used to
pretend he was until we found out he was
banging some other chick while his
wife was dying of cancer and apparently
fucking physically
threatened her and you know,
yeah,
he's a fucking use campaign funds to
hide the fact that he was banging this
broad.
So now he's probably going to go to jail.
This is there.
It's fucking going after John Edwards.
But at one point in time,
John Edwards was this lawyer with good
old fashion American values and pull them
up by your bootstraps,
you know,
work ethic and you know,
you,
you'd come to find out that it is
impossible to be a pure person,
to be the guy that
you're pretending to be,
to be a politician.
They push it back so far that
eventually it pops out somewhere.
It blows out there dressing up like a
tiger and taking pictures or Al Gore
fucking tries to get his dick sucked
while he's getting a massage and the chick
wants a sec,
you know,
charge them with sexual assault.
You know,
there's some truth.
There's something,
something happened there.
You know,
I don't know what it was.
She might have overblown it.
He might've just rubbed his cock
honor just as like a little tester.
Who knows what the fuck happened.
But whatever happened,
it's not what we thought Al Gore was.
We didn't think Al Gore was whipping his
dick out and fucking hotels was getting
massaged.
We didn't think that was,
he was pulling girls on top of them.
We didn't think that was Al Gore.
I don't know if he did that,
but he did enough or got into a situation
that was enough for him to get in
trouble.
You know?
I mean,
no one talks about what Winston
Churchill did with his women like that.
That was like,
it didn't fucking matter.
Fighting the Nazis.
He was kicking ass.
And I think all our politicians now,
they're so fraudulent.
And what their kind of projecting
that it does matter at this point.
It's like you're a hypocritical
lying little bastard.
But if they were real,
like really doing shit and very honest
with what they're attacking and the
issues they were attacking were honest
and they were coming from a real place.
It's like,
oh yeah,
our fucking fearless leader after a big,
you know,
a tough night.
He had some,
you know,
sexual indiscretion,
whatever,
you forgive that stuff.
But when they build
this foundation full of,
you know,
puritanical nonsense,
then they do that.
They feel like that's the only
way to get elected though.
And there's so much power in bullshit
today with the idea of the Christian
ideology and the,
you know,
the Christian,
right.
And the fucking,
you know,
so Uber judgmental and that,
that there's,
that's a big political push because
those people were organized.
Those,
those,
the really right wing
Christian fundamentalists that,
that movement,
that's a very organized movement.
And if they're on your side,
you can do a lot of damage.
And if they're against you,
it can really hurt.
You know,
if they do organize the churches and
they all said pull out and they say,
well,
this is fucking,
Al Gore doesn't believe in Jesus.
Oh fuck him.
You know,
they'll go crazy.
You have to fake that
you believe in Jesus,
whether you do or not,
you better say you do because you're,
if you say you don't,
you're going to piss off 50 fucking
percent of the country and you're never
gonna get anything done.
Yeah,
yeah.
Fuck situation.
And I think that's why,
you know,
there's the shamans down there when they
talk about 2012 they talk about it just
as a tipping point.
But that,
that's like,
that's,
they talked about it.
Yeah.
Well they said that 2012
is the tipping point.
That's when the
world has to start changing and it will,
uh,
upheavals will happen.
They don't know if it's
going to be economic.
They don't know if it's going to be,
you know,
physical,
it's not the end of time
or anything like that.
And that was,
it was kind of cool to
hear them talk about it.
So like that's all nonsense.
It's all hype.
What it is is it's the point at which
things must start changing for us.
Why is there a date?
Why is it,
do I think it's December 21st,
2012 or was it 2012 at all?
It's to a astrological restaurant.
Comical kind of event,
right?
Isn't there some kind of
the alignment I've heard,
I didn't,
obviously I'm not an astronomer,
but I've heard Neil Tyson talk
about how that's bullshit into that.
That event happens all the
time that everyone's talking
about how it aligns with
the center of the galaxy and he's like
can always does to happens all the time.
Yeah.
Well,
so I don't know.
I don't exactly know
how they got the date.
I mean I think it was tied
to some kind of of going on
in this,
in the,
in the idea of astrology and astronomy,
there's so much going on where you know,
they can figure out that the moon is off
a little bit with its gravity and then
they have to figure out what is
responsible for this error and the moon's
gravity will,
it could be a brown dwarf star that lays,
you know,
a hundred million miles outside of Pluto.
And that's like the
current theory is in it.
But they can figure that out.
They can figure it out.
They couldn't measure gravity and know
that there's errors in places and try to
like figure out what y where's
this error coming from.
So we know that that for sure that the
moon's effect and its particular gravity
has an effect on tides.
We believe it has an
effect on human behavior,
although that's all subjective.
But we,
we know that these little bodies or these,
these,
these motions and these,
these things that we can't quite grab a
hold of have a very physical effect on
the earth.
Like in the tide w who knows how many
different things are doing that all the
time with the procession of the equinoxes,
the fact that the earth
wobbles on its access,
uh,
26,000 year cycle.
And in between that times,
you know,
you never know what is aligned with what,
when you were brought into this world
and that the idea behind astrology as
fucking flaky and new agey
and bullshitty as it sounds,
is that these events,
these alignments of
stars and positions of,
of the moon and all
these different things,
they actually affect how a human being
is charged as they're set loose from the
vagina into the world.
You know,
that it,
that it actually has on it and it look,
it fucking,
I know a lot of Leos,
it seemed like Leo's,
you know,
I know a lot of cancers
that act like cancer.
I mean,
fuck it sounds like utter horse shit,
but God damn it's fucking clothes.
It seems,
it seems damn close.
Yeah.
So yeah,
I mean,
I don't know exactly what the,
uh,
what the event is that
they named the date for.
They didn't go into that.
But what they said is that a new type of
person has to emerge at that point and
that the old ways have to change and
they will and that things will get fucked
up enough where they have to.
It's like,
it's not like we all got a rally and you,
but we do.
And when we do it to a certain degree,
we have to prepare for it,
but it'll,
it'll force itself to happen.
So we just need to be ready
for it as what they're saying.
Like the new era is going to come and
it's going to happen either complete
economic upheaval,
physical upheaval of the earth.
Um,
whatever's going to happen
is going to force our hand.
And then the new people are
going to have to emerge.
They call it the legend
of Catsa Quadel defense,
the feathered serpent.
But really that represents the new type
of human that comes and starts taking a
leadership role.
So all of these cock picturing
politicians and everything,
whatever they believe is going to happen
is going to change that paradigm where
all of a sudden that becomes deemphasized
either faith in them gets lost,
a new system as to emerge.
New leaders,
new,
you know,
political.
Is this,
the Shamans have actually
explained this to you?
Yeah.
Did they talk about the Internet?
Are they on Twitter?
How come on,
you can tell,
you can tell the mountain the mountain
shamans are dim at different than the
jungle shamans.
But you can tell a good mountain Sharman
by how much he smells like burnt Lama
Shit because that's how they
stay warm up in the high parts.
So it'd be really be really,
look,
it really smells like burnt Lama Shit.
You know,
he's probably authentic cause then he's
up up above 15,000 feet for most of
them.
Jesus Christ,
but no cell phone,
no Internet.
And he's missing the cool youtube videos.
Some one of them,
one of the guys that had,
uh,
I was talking with,
had a,
at a full URL at the bottom
of his little corner.
So they're starting to adapt to it.
Nice seeing you.
They need that.
There's,
you know,
people poo poo the cultural experience,
because it's filled with
morons and lady Gaga fans.
But there's nothing wrong with lady Gaga.
Okay.
That's part of the trip and
I think she's fascinating.
I like some of her music.
How about that?
And there's nothing wrong with the
rest of the cultural experiments.
Even the most ridiculous aspects of it.
It's all part of us,
you know?
And you don't want to be locked out.
I don't buy that being locked out
when I talked to someone and go,
I don't know if you have an email,
well you're a fucking moron.
How about that?
You don't want an email.
You don't want people to be able to
send you cool shit that you can read.
You didn't want photos.
That'll blow your mind.
You don't want someone turning you on to
some fucking article that might change
your life.
You don't want that.
Okay,
you're cool too cool for that.
What are you going to do?
Sniff flowers.
You fucking Weirdo
for them.
It's like,
I mean,
really,
do they want to just affect only
the few people in the village?
If you're a real shot and be like,
yeah,
fuck yeah,
I want to get my word out there.
I want to make change.
I want to make things happen.
And I think it goes back to kind of what
Pressfield says about professionals,
like the professional,
the shamans down there were professionals.
They're not trying to be shamans.
They just fucking are.
That's their job.
That's what they do.
And they're professionals at it.
So yeah,
the Internet comes along,
they analyze that tool and they're like,
oh yeah,
that's cool.
You know?
Or if something funny happens
in the middle of their ceremony,
they're not like,
I better not laugh.
Or people might think
that I'm not a showman.
You know?
They're like,
they'll fucking crack up and be like,
ah.
And then they'll just get back
to their work when they're done.
They don't take themselves so seriously
that it's like anything could shake the
experience.
It's not for other people.
They're going to do their work and
whatever happens when they do their work,
that's fine.
They go with it.
And that was something I really appreciate
it because even when you get out here
in this kind of slightly
pseudo spiritual thing,
it's like they're putting on an act,
you know,
like the music has to be perfect and
the candles have to grow with the
right and the crystal has to be without
impurities,
you know?
And they're like,
okay,
you know,
if they use rocks,
they're like,
this is a good rock,
you know,
and it just looks like a fucking rock
spiritual bullshit.
Spiritual talk is the grossest shit.
Yeah.
I got married by a hack.
We got some lady off the
Internet that married.
I said,
oh,
it was brutal.
Your love is two streams that will
become together a growing river.
It will wash over the rocks of the world.
Like,
oh,
you crazy bitch.
There was no feeling to it at all.
Like as she was saying it,
there was no connection to the words.
It was just utter spiritual
nonsense because it was a
nondenominational wedding,
obviously,
because I'm not religious.
Nora's Mrs Rogan.
So it had a listen to this nonsense
crystal sucking fucking ideas.
Marriott world of Narnia.
Yeah.
This bitch lived at totally in Narnia.
She had a hut in Narnia.
It was brutal.
This,
um,
I found the article about
the Colombian showman.
He was arrested in Texas and
charged with IOWASCA possession.
He flew into the Houston airport.
And the crazy thing about being charged
with Iowasca possession is the plants
that you use to create
Iowasca or not even illegal.
That's the weirdest aspect of it.
You know,
I met the guy from
bouncing bear botanicals.
He came to my show in Vegas.
Yeah.
Uh,
if you don't know the story,
there was a guy who ran a website called
bouncing bear botanicals and it's a
website all dedicated to selling legal
plants that have psychedelic properties
to them.
Like the San Pedro Cactus that you
could buy at fucking home depot.
Yeah.
Well you can make
Mescalin out of that shit.
You can,
you can open that bitch up,
make some Payoti if you know what
you're doing and trip your balls off.
This is off some shit that you just buy
at home depot and it's totally legal.
It's a beautiful cactus and a lot
of people don't even know about the
psychedelic properties of it.
They have it just to decorate
their garden because it's pretty,
but it's not illegal.
So they,
they,
he has this there,
he's selling this,
he's selling the different circuitry had
Veritas and the different plants that
you mix to make Iowasca
he's selling those.
He's selling Salvia.
I sang all these different plants that
are absolutely legal morning glory seeds.
You know a lot of people
don't know that morning glory,
seeds,
just those regular fucking seeds that
you buy when you go to plant to make
flowers.
Well the ones that you buy,
most of them,
they've been treated so that they are
not psychoactive because regular morning
glory seeds,
you can grind those bitches up and eat
them and you'll trip your fucking balls
off.
Hell yeah.
So untreated,
they're still your,
their legal,
you can buy the untreated
ones.
It's hard to get,
it's hard to get the untreated ones.
You're supposed to treat them because the
government is aware of the psychedelic
properties of them.
Meanwhile,
you know,
of course it's not nearly as dangerous
as cigarettes or alcohol or any of the
things they sanction,
but it's to mind bending for the
government allowed the unwashed masses to
participate in.
So your wise daddy government is figured
out how to neuter this incredibly
brilliant psychedelic plant to the point
where most people aren't even aware of
its properties.
But regular morning glory seeds was
Terence Mckenna's first psychedelic trip.
That's what sent him on his
fucking wacky journey of,
you know,
being psychedelic Shawman of the,
the new world.
Um,
and that was a,
you know,
a common thing that people did in the
70s and the 60s before the government got
hip to it.
They were just tripping balls
and morning glory seeds,
you know.
So this guy,
this John or he says that was saying
from bouncing bear botanicals.
Anyway,
there's two dudes that I met that came,
they were high as fuck there was so high,
I can barely talk to them after the show.
They came to my last Vegas show and I
talked to them outside and that swarm of
people,
remember there's all two of
those of those crazy guys.
They were trying to have like
a serious conversation with me.
Me,
it was like 500 people trying to take
pictures and they want to hold on in my
hand and talk to him.
I'm like,
dude,
wasn't a lot of people here.
I can't remember to talk
to you about your arrest.
Glad you're doing the right thing.
Glad you got out.
But apparently they let him out of jail.
They had to let him
out eventually because,
uh,
there's,
you know,
there's nothing he can
fucking charge him for there.
There's nothing that said that
he was making drugs trashed.
His place crashes,
confiscated all the state.
I don't know if he got his money back,
but they froze all that
as well for nothing,
for nothing.
Because the government is
scared of psychedelics.
It's amazing how scared they are of it.
And I guarantee you they're scared of
it because they're not experiencing it.
It's that simple.
Like when you get into like
Alex Jones believes crazy shit.
Like he believes that the
elites were all smoking DMT.
Like they're all up in,
you know,
Hilton Talk to you about,
they're all in fucking and
shit where Guantanamo Bay,
they're all down in Guantanamo
Bay and they are smoking DMT,
connecting to the spirit world.
They believe in eternal life
what they're going to do.
And he'll tell you all this nonsense that
he absolutely positively believes in,
but I believe 100% you cannot smoke
DMT and not be empathetic towards other
people that are doing it.
You cannot take Iowa school or mushrooms
without being empathetic and wanting
other people to do it.
These people that are trying
to keep everybody from it,
those are the people sending their dicks
to their fucking secretaries and their
emails.
Those are the fucking hypocrite,
hypocritical shitheads with huge flaws
and their character that we have running
this country and running this world.
And unfortunately that's,
that's one of our biggest issues
are what we considered leaders.
We know for sure that it's a
bullshit scam and we allow it.
We have,
we have resigned ourselves.
We know that the president
has speech writers.
We know that everyone has a bunch of
people that will review every word that
he's going to say and it's going to be
calculated and they're going to sit down
and come up with the,
the the right words and enact the most
emotional impact to the point where they
even fucking,
they used to plagiarize other people's
speeches before they got busted for it.
Joe Biden,
our own fucking vice
president used to plagiarize.
He blew plagiarized Kennedy Shit.
Well,
they caught them doing that in 1,988
that's why he had to quit running for
president,
you know,
and that's why he had to like sit in
the background and wait for everybody to
kind of forget about it before
he could be vice president.
You know,
we know for a fact that it's,
it's a,
it's a bullshit hustle.
We're all aware of lobbyists.
We're all aware of special interest groups
and corporations donating millions of
dollars.
We're all aware that the supreme court
changed the ruling so that a corporation
can now act as an individual.
So they can donate as much
fucking money as they want,
which is absurd.
The idea that a corporation that
would rely on politicians and their,
their,
their decisions to make money in a
way that may or may not be ethical,
but they'll rely on and then they just
donated x amount of fucking millions of
dollars towards this person.
It's insane.
It's amazing.
And we accept it for now because
things are relatively placid,
you know?
Yeah.
We have some little few
financial difficulties,
but whatever people's lives,
they go on and we go and you know what
they're saying about 2012 is had at
certain point things aren't going
to be fucking plastic anymore.
And at that point we're not
going to accept that bullshit.
We're not going to expect except these
weak ass politicians who don't really
stand for anything to lead us anymore.
So what's going to happen?
Who the fuck knows?
They don't know.
They don't have the answer,
but they're going to say some type of
new person is going to have to emerge and
be like,
Yo,
this is bullshit.
Like we needed to make some changes now.
Like things are getting fucked up,
even worse and worse.
Have you seen the,
the,
the numbers that they did when they were,
they did an audit of the,
uh,
the Fed to find out where the fucking
money went for the bailout and they found
trillions of dollars that went to
these weird fucking overseas banks.
And it's totally beyond description how
much corruption and ridiculous bullshit
is involved and how little accountability
there is for this distribution of,
of the taxpayers wealth.
I mean,
it's a fucking free for all,
man.
It's craziness.
So it's to say that there's
a few financial difficulties.
The whole thing is built on
this foundation of unfixable
bullshit and there's no
solution in sight.
Yeah,
that's worse.
I mean,
that is getting more credit
rating about to be downgraded.
China already did.
They downgraded our credit rating
even though we didn't default,
even though we raised our,
our,
our debt ceiling,
they're like,
these bitches are like on the edge.
You know,
it's like when you try
to get too many loans,
even if you pay your loans back,
the banks are going,
why are you asking for all this money?
Dude,
what are you,
what's going on with you?
But you've got a gambling problem.
But yeah,
it's,
it's not,
it's not fucking getting
fixed in the system.
And this,
the,
the way it's set up right now and
the model that we're operating under,
it's not getting fixed
and everyone's frustrated.
No one knows that knows what to do.
And me like you,
like I'm the fucking
completely full of Shit.
All I do is just complain about it.
And then I go about my day and as long
as I have food in the refrigerator and I
have the ability to use
my credit card to buy gas,
I'm only gonna Yap too much.
You know,
it almost like it has to fall apart on
all of us before we step back and we go,
all right,
well now we have to admit
doesn't work right?
Well what you're doing,
but you're doing something
more important than that,
I think as well,
is that you're creating a
movement of consciousness.
I mean every time new
people turn it tune in,
you know you have their
ear and these people,
but I have no activated of no,
there's no crisis yet necessarily.
Right.
It's sort of where is though.
No,
kind of.
Probably if we had the foresight to
really look ahead and start doing things
now,
but it's not pressured enough like it's
not beating down our door so it's just
really not going to happen.
Realistically,
we probably not that we shouldn't
try and do it or whatever.
I'm not saying that,
but so much work though.
That's the problem.
If you want to live your life at
some point when things get fucked,
you know you may have,
this is the Joe Rogan
fucking emergency podcasts.
Listen,
like this is what needs to happen.
Like seriously and you'll have,
you'll have that power like fucking
John Connor for your own small people of
conscious fucking humans who are going
to be able to then go out and like,
all right,
everything we're being fed is nonsense.
Don't use it.
The shit goes down.
The Internet is going to be
the first thing they shut off.
They tried to do that in another country.
So they have,
they've done it.
But yeah,
there were did in Libya
when they do it in Egypt,
Egypt.
But there was still ways around it.
People were still getting mad.
He's going to intentionally fuck us.
I just think they're going to be
incapable of helping us at that point.
You know,
like that's my personal belief.
I don't think I'd be like,
shut the internet down.
It's just gonna be like,
ah,
what do we do?
We're a bunch of,
you know,
we've never fucking stuck our
hand in a glove full of ants.
We are not ready for this shit
either.
Or though.
Right.
Good Bait could come either or.
I mean,
there's a reason why they do these
fucking FEMA tests and they have,
you know,
giant stockpiles of plastic coffins,
that's all been documented.
They've prepared,
they have a lot of drills they prepared
for mass extinction events and you know,
big,
huge environmental catastrophes.
Natural disasters.
I mean,
the government has camps,
they have FEMA camps and these are real,
you know,
this is Alex Jones.
You know when he'll,
he'll start talking about FEMA camps,
but there's,
there's a real,
they're really do have places where
they have cots set up and they have,
they have fucking,
almost like a prisoner of war camp because
if the shit really does hit the fan,
you know,
we get wiped out in
nuclear war or you know,
or,
or a fucking asteroid hits or something
nutty that fucks up the world.
We really are going to have to detain a
lot of people were really going to have
to calm everybody the fuck down.
If we're going to evacuate areas,
we're going to have to have
places to shelter these people.
We're going to have to have buses were
women and children are crying and they're
being separated from the father and
the father sitting there with a son and
we'll meet you at the camp and then that's
real shit and they're going to get on
buses and we're not going to know
where everybody is and we're not,
some people are not going to be,
that's possible.
This is a fucking
fragile world we live in.
Yeah,
it's possible.
You know,
and little,
and then little colonies will get set up.
Individuals will have different,
you know,
who knows how the,
but the structure could break and at
that point some new system can emerge.
It's almost,
that's when we have to bring in the
Colombians bringing that fucking Iowasca
donkeys in big clay pots
riding on the back of Don.
He's in the whole wage.
Oh Ya,
Ya go?
Yeah.
You got it,
man.
Yeah,
I can get in there,
dude.
I could get down.
I can get done with the Iwatch carols.
You Cut.
So what'd they say about smoking DMT?
Would they say?
Well,
they said that
that's just kind of a,
it's kind of a rocket ship that plants
you right in that it right in that sixth
dimension,
but only the sixth dimension.
The seventh and the eighth,
they say mostly.
Mostly not because it's
too short of an experience.
You can't really,
you have to kind of
gather steam through the,
through the dimensions
or something like that.
And the smoking DMT kind of skips over
the fifth where you usually kind of start
getting in these dreams.
It's like Wham,
Bam into the six.
And that's why they say that
there's some disorientation there.
A lot of lessons to be learned and wisdom.
Anytime you sneak outside of time,
which is how they describe it
as sneaking outside of time,
you have lessons to learn,
but they're,
you know,
once you're there you have a short window
of time and you're trying to absorb as
much as possible.
Um,
but the forces aren't
there to align you to help,
you know,
kind of push you farther because that's,
that's a process you
have to gain knowledge.
Like what happened to me,
I had to download something or whatever
they said in the seventh to get,
you know,
to get that far.
They're like,
just have more steam
and energy to get there.
And they talk about it as fuel.
You know,
the problem with the smoking
DMT is the fuel runs out.
They have enough fuel to
like get you into orbit,
you know,
but it's not that extra afterburner
that's going to come in and shoot you to
Mars after you're outside
of the atmosphere.
You know,
eventually it's just going
to suck you right back in.
And so that's what they say.
The,
the differences
between those,
the interesting because the intravenous
doses of DMT that like Strassman did in
those studies,
those people had 30 minute trips.
That's,
so I wonder if that's enough.
I wonder if that's a different
teacher to a different place.
I didn't get to ask as opposed to be
a more intense experience when it's
experienced.
Um,
when it's done intravenously,
it's supposed to be more a more
in depth and a lot more entities.
Yeah.
A lot more people being uh,
you know,
more of what they would describe.
That sounds remarkably similar
to Ufo abduction experiences.
You know,
that kind of thing that you're dealing
with these physical things in this other
place.
Yeah.
It's a real fucking symptom of our
culture that that shit's all illegal.
That people can like,
you can come back and you get so fucked
up that you have to change your name and
it's still illegal.
It's illegal.
You know,
a,
it's really annoying.
It's really annoying that we're
in this fucking nanny state.
It's shitbag stupid nanny state country.
Yeah.
Do you find you any side effects at all?
Like does your mind wander in
places over and over again?
Do you have any different now?
What was the,
some of the challenges
were just reintegrating,
you know,
and a lot of that's just you to this
different world and experience different
things and,
but do you leave your life on
the treadmill running full speed,
you know?
And I tried to hop right back the fuck
on and I got tripped up and slammed
against the back wall.
You know?
Do you use that analogy?
Like it's hard to get back,
you know,
and hard to find,
kind of the balance of integrating what,
what you found out they're not.
But
do you guys feel like the world
doesn't seem the same when you,
when you came back,
do you feel that anything's
changed in the world?
No.
You know,
I,
I feel like,
you know,
I've,
I've changed the way I
look at things has changed.
You know,
the fact that I can,
I view myself now more like a needle
piercing a nine layered onion.
You know,
and I'm,
you're consciously
aware of the first four,
four layers,
you know,
that part of the needle,
but you're still connected to another
five layers above you and you're just,
you just don't see it,
you know,
just that very thought alone has changed,
has changed my life.
You know,
it's hard to incorporate in
every day and everyday things.
I mean,
I've been focused pretty much solely on
launching Alpha brain and making sure
that all goes well and it's been very,
you know,
very focused on that.
But in my quiet moments,
you know,
when I can meditate,
I can think back and think,
you know,
what I want to do next time I go down
there and what lessons I could learn and
how,
oh,
he did an isolation tank son.
That's your next step.
I do.
We sell some of these Alpha brains
enough to get you one morning glory.
And so this is,
this is the shit that we've been talking
about on Twitter and we've talked about
it on the podcast before and this is a
formula that Chris has put together and
that we're selling and
it's called Alpha brain,
and it fucking does something man.
It first of all,
it gives you incredibly vivid dreams
and it seems to fire up your brain at a
higher rpm level or give you some clarity.
I feel like it helps me
form sentences better,
you know?
You know what I'm saying?
I mean,
I don't know that that's what's doing it,
but I feel like,
man,
I'm fucking talking pretty smooth
sometimes when I'm on this stuff.
Technically what they say is that it
enhances Sydney synaptic plasticity,
which is the way that your neurons
can kind of fit together and transfer
information
that,
was this all peer reviewed
stuff or is it spiritual?
No,
it's a c rolling.
Yeah.
This is,
this is purely on the scientific tap here.
And what's it,
what's in here?
So what it is,
it's
a GPC calling,
which is a great form of rock hauling,
the best form of rock.
Coleen really glycerophosphocholine
easily absorbed through the blood brain
barrier where some of the
other Coline's or not.
So it's most expensive
and best calling for you.
And then we have hoopers Ia Serrata,
which has a proven compound
called huperzine a,
which is an Acetylcholine
esterase inhibitor and that
prevents the breakdown of
the Acetylcholine in your brain.
And what does see the calling
is in charge of is in charge of,
you know,
focus,
memory,
clarity,
uh,
all the Alzheimer's treatments.
Currently almost all of them focus on
rehabilitating your acetylcholine levels
in boosting your acetylcholine.
So even who presented a,
which is part of the Hoop Herzliya
Serrata has been tested in that capacity.
So this is all very,
you know,
very scientifically proven.
This is not anything Hokey pokey is
just the fact hire a pseudo cdot.
Coleen levels lead to this.
Now the problem with higher
acetylcholine levels,
otherwise everybody would just be
jacked jacking their acetylcholine up,
is it can lead to anxiety,
anxiousness,
a short temper.
If that's too out of balance,
you can get other,
you can get kind of hyper aware.
And so what I did with this formula,
as I said,
all right,
we want to have strong acetylcholine.
It's good,
it helps your memory,
helps your mental drives,
help you focus.
But we don't want to have
all the other things.
So I created a balanced formula and I
included things like Gabba which controls
kind of relaxation and kind of calm
and mental clarity in that kind of calm
state.
And then dopamine,
which handles a lot of your movement
activities and some of your mental energy
activities.
Yeah,
added dopamine.
Well,
um,
it's Mucuna pruriens uh,
contains a standardized
dose of 50% ELL Dopa and um,
you can appear.
Ends is a herb,
I think,
believe it grows in India.
And so the 50% standardized l Dopa
is the building block for dopamine.
So yeah,
I didn't add dopamine.
I actually,
you're able to add a Gabba directly
because they're able to extract it from a
plant.
But the dopamine you have to get through,
you know,
pushing l Dopa and your body,
your body will destroy it opened me.
And if you try to put it in directly
so you build it yourself with El Dopa,
uh,
the catalyst and that is again,
um,
the pyridoxine Hcl,
vitamin B six which we have in there,
which helps convert it.
So,
and then,
then I've just put a ton of antioxidants
that are going to give you energy,
uh,
help your focus.
The ACA 11 in there that was shown
to actually repair DNA and uh,
scientific peer reviewed studies.
So really fucking strong antioxidants
going to kind of eliminate some of that
mental fog,
cleared out some of your free radicals
and then allow the acetylcholine a boost
to be manageable by the other,
by the other components.
Yeah.
Have you ever thought about
adding five HTP to it?
Now that's another formula that I have
and Serotonin is a crucial component.
Five HTP is the direct
building block of Serotonin.
Um,
it goes l Tryptophan to five HTP,
five ht HTP then converts to five ht,
which is serotonin.
That's the fourth component.
I have another separate formula,
the rollover formula,
which is specifically focused
on building serotonin.
So,
uh,
being the fact that I have that there,
there's just not that much room in the
capsules and it is important to have,
but I recommend that,
um,
you know,
that doesn't tend to,
that doesn't need to be so much in
balance for this formula to work,
but it is a crucial part of things.
So I recommend either taking my
formula or another form of five HTP,
but it was just a little bit much to
fit and efficacious dose of five HTP in
this Alpha brain to bring
that forth component.
It,
that's too bad because I know a lot of
people that have had a lot of positive
effects with the five HTP is great.
That's why I have a whole
product rowboat and roll over,
roll over.
Yeah.
My product rollover is
dedicated specifically to that.
So you have a,
you're selling those
and much smaller selling
like four of those bottles,
a 30 get bottles of 30 just like this.
Yeah.
And so do you recommend
people taking that?
If they're not coming off of,
uh,
you know,
the roll on roll off,
it's supposed to be like you do Mtma
and then you're welcome anytime.
If you're not sleeping,
if you're stressed and
you're not sleeping,
that's when Serotonin is
produced is when you're sleeping.
So if you're not sleeping,
it doesn't matter if you're
partying and if you are doing,
doing whatever you're doing,
you're not going to be
producing enough serotonin.
Right.
So that's when you need to take it.
Uh,
so yeah,
I certainly recommend taking
it as part of the regimen.
I mean that formula will probably change
a little bit and the next iteration I
have some ideas for it,
but I'm going to always have
a serotonin specific formula.
Um,
you know,
if,
if enough people want to have this Alpha
brain be that complete brain thing,
we can look at it.
But just as far as dose and capsule size,
it's difficult to do everything.
I mean,
I have a capsule that's
specifically designed for Serotonin,
the whole capsule capsule.
It'd be way too much.
It's tough.
So you,
so that one was something that
I do recommend I do sell on,
on at.com,
but,
um,
it's not in the Alpha brain,
but I highly recommend it.
It's a great,
it's a great thing to have.
I use it all the time.
I love it.
I don't take it every day,
but I definitely take it on like days
where I for sure feel jacked up in it.
I think I,
I've been taking for like,
I don't know,
like six,
eight months here and there and I,
I,
it's one of my favorite things.
I though the roll on and roll
overs are my two favorite things.
Yeah.
Those,
so those formulas will
change a little bit,
but I'm still going to always
keep that kind of concept and not,
you know,
the Alpha brains,
it's getting great feedback.
I know,
you know,
all of us here,
we all take it and we dig it.
So,
uh,
there's something going on with it.
Most certainly does have an effect.
Um,
like I said,
it gives me the most incredible dreams.
Okay.
So the reason why that's happening
is acetylcholine regulates rem sleep.
That's what determines,
you know,
you get a wash of Acetylcholine,
uh,
during your rem sleep.
So the fact that you have excess surpluses
of Acetylcholine created by the GPC
calling her Perseus serrata
allows a deeper and broader
wash of Acetylcholine to
go through,
uh,
your sleep cycles.
And so your rem sleep
becomes way more intense,
longer and more vivid then,
uh,
when you do have low
levels of Acetylcholine.
All right,
so if you guys want to grab this,
it's available now and
on it.com o n n I t.com.
And uh,
it's called Alpha brain.
And tell me how you like it.
I know some people have already
started taking it and uh,
I have yet to talk to one person that
hasn't had positive experiences with it.
And um,
it's uh,
no,
what is it,
30 bucks for 30 of these things.
And people say,
oh,
it's expensive,
but look,
this,
the stuff's not cheap stuff.
It's,
it's what's needed to
actually have an effect.
Yeah,
I went expensive the best.
I got the best ingredients I could,
you know,
I cut no corners.
Everything's full spectrum standardize.
So this is the best product
I can make and you know,
I hope people dig it because I fucking,
I played my cards as well as I can and,
and tried to make the best
in every aspect of doing it.
Yeah.
Thanks for coming on and talking about
your psychedelic experience that made you
change your name.
I mean we thinking get you drunk on Jack
Daniels and you go to B and Duke turn
you into some sort of fucking,
after listening to that story though,
I would definitely change
my name to it seems like,
and you've actually got to sit in that
thing and we talked with the ancient
aliens guy,
the the big square that was cut out.
You got to,
you got the crew.
Yeah.
He's got a photo of him sitting in there.
When we were talking to a Joe Su,
Su sucralose from a ancient aliens,
he was talking to us about this area in
Peru where this stone is cut out and you
could see it,
if you'd go to the Ustream page,
he put a picture of Chris,
excuse me,
Aubrey sitting inside this,
this rock where it was cut out where
they have no idea how they cut it out
because it was,
it's really,
you have to see it.
What is the name of the place again?
It's in the roads in the sacred valley.
I forget the name of
this actual ruin site,
uh,
calming to me,
but it's,
um,
I,
it was right there near,
uh,
you know,
it's outside of Cusco by about an hour
and a half and you get to these ruin
sites.
Either way,
it's dope.
Go get some Alpha brain stupid.
Yeah.
It does seem like one of the places
too bad he can't do Iowasca there.
That would be the shit.
Yeah.
I think that sounds fucking bad ass do
Iowasca at Chichen Itza or Machu Picchu
or something like that.
Yeah.
At the ruins of some ancient civilization.
That that's what they,
that's what they develop Machu
Picchu for as a spiritual center.
Actually really it wasn't
like a political center.
This was their spiritual home.
Where did you hear that?
The rituals?
Um,
the people there for me cause I thought
the cause modern Western folks have no
fucking idea why it was created.
They don't have an idea.
No,
he had the Shaman Saul say this was there,
this was created as their
spiritual home and that's,
and that's why they created
it in such an odd spot.
The way that the mountains are around.
There's speaking of law civilizations,
I'll be in Milwaukee
August 13th at the Pabst
theater with Joey Coco Diaz.
Tickets are on sale right now and uh,
it's like half sold out already,
so don't sleep.
And then also on September 23rd,
Joey and I will be in Denver,
Colorado at the paramount theater.
And that is also just about half sold
out now Denver showing lots of love.
I can't wait to come back to Colorado
where I will eventually go when the shit
hits the fan and society crumbles.
And I have to live in the
woods near where my dog died.
Folks,
that's the end of this fucking show.
We've had a fantastic time.
Chris and I are going to
go check out red state.
We're going to go see the premiere of
Kevin Smith new movie and we'll have a
full report on that.
Thank you very much for
tuning into the podcast.
Please follow Chris on Twitter.
His,
excuse me,
Aubrey is his name,
his warrior poet,
That's on Twitter.
Follow Red Ban.
He's very upset about his Twitter numbers.
Obsesses on it on a daily.
And why you ran it.
Follow me to your fucking freaks.
We're not falling Joe already.
You're ridiculous.
How dare you.
How dare you if you're not following me.
I'm trying to hit a million people.
I'm only at 413,000.
I don't feel validated.
All right.
That was a moment of weakness.
Back to reality.
Thank you everybody for tuning in.
We uh,
we love you all and uh,
we,
we wish you well on your spiritual
journey through the world of snakes.
Did and go to that with a fleshlight end.
If you go to Joe rogan.net thank you.
The fleshlight for sponsoring the podcast.
If you go to Joe rogan.net and click
the link for the flashlight and entering
the code named Rogan,
you will get 15% off the
number one sex toy for men,
and then you can shoot
loads at a discount.
How the Shama feel about sex toys?
Are they cool with that?
I think they're down.
He's got like five kids though.
Have you could use,
you could use one day.
Pulled up on his urges.
She was not shy about sex out there.
Shazamm we'll see next week.
Love you.
Bye Bye.
[inaudible].